[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
Welcome to Let's Talk,
Designing Quality Conversations
for Google Assistant.
My name is Jessica Early-Cha,
and I'm a Developer Advocate
for Actions on Google.
CATHY PEARL: And I'm Cathy
Pearl, Head of Conversation
Design Outreach.
And if you want to
tweet about our talk,
that would be awesome.
Be sure and use the
hashtag AoGDevs.
Over the last few
days you've been
hearing a lot about
how developers
can add their content
to the Google Assistant
by creating something
called an action.
And you can think
of an action kind
of like an application on our
platform, Actions on Google.
And it enables people
to have a conversation
with a Google Assistant
about any content
that you want to put out there.
And it'll be available on
lots of different devices,
and we've got tools and options
to help you get started.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Definitely--
there's tons of different ways
to make an action.
And we actually recently
released several new ways.
And so if you're
a content owner,
let's say you have a how to
guide or video on YouTube,
you can add that content
using templates or markup.
If you're an Android
developer, you
could connect your Android
app to Google Assistant
with App Actions.
And of course, if you're
a hardware developer,
you want to connect all
your really cool devices
using our Smart home SDK.
And what's really cool
is, the first three--
Google Assistant handles the
natural language processing
for you.
So you don't have to manage the
back and forth and figuring out
what the user really
means, which is fantastic.
But what's really,
really great is
there is a space where you
could be really creative.
And this is where we
have conversation actions
and using tools like
Interactive Canvas, where
you create completely new
experiences for your users.
CATHY PEARL: And as
Jessica mentioned,
sometimes the how tos, the App
Actions, and things like that
aren't necessarily
everything you
need to create your interesting
and complex experience.
So in that case a custom
action is a great way to go.
And when you build a custom
action in particular,
you really need to
think about design.
We've all had very
frustrating experiences
with our voice assistance.
And a lot of times
that's not because there
was a technical issue, but
because it was poorly designed.
And we want to help you
build the best custom
actions possible.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
And we know that when
designers and developers,
when we work together,
quality goes up.
And the likelihood of users
returning to your action
goes up, too.
CATHY PEARL: We also know
that not every developer has
their own personal designer.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
[LAUGHS] Thank you.
So today we're going
to walk through a bunch
of different examples
and things we
could do today to make
better quality conversations.
CATHY PEARL: So let's talk
about conversation design
and the first rule of
conversation design
is to write sample dialogues.
You can think of
a sample dialogue
kind of like a movie script.
It's basically a back and
forth between your user
and the Assistant.
And it's a great
way to get started
brainstorming,
trying out new ideas,
sharing them with stakeholders.
And don't worry about
getting them perfect.
Because believe me, the
first time I write my sample
dialogue, it's never perfect.
It's never the thing
I use in the end.
Just remember that old rule--
there's no such thing
as good writing,
there is only good rewriting.
And just like when
you're in Hollywood
and you're writing a movie
script, you do a table read.
You read them out loud.
Take your sample dialogues,
find a few people,
read them back and forth.
It's great if you
can find someone
to be your user who's not
familiar with your design.
And you will quickly
discover problems and bugs
that you had no idea
were there before you've
written a single line of code.
So Jessica, why don't we do
a sample dialogue right here,
right now, on stage?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Sounds great.
CATHY PEARL: All right.
Let's say we're going
to make an action that
lets you rate jokes.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: OK.
CATHY PEARL: Will
you be my user?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Of
course, I'll be the user.
And you'll be the action.
CATHY PEARL: All right.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: OK.
Hey, Google, talk to Joke Rater.
CATHY PEARL: Welcome
to Joke Rater.
I'll tell you a joke,
and you can rate it.
Are you ready?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Yah.
CATHY PEARL: All right.
What's brown and sticky?
A stick.
Now I'm not sure if I'm
going to have them rate it,
like, one to five, or
a Likert scale or--
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
Remember, Cathy, we're
supposed to just do
the sample dialogue,
not what actually happened.
CATHY PEARL: All right.
Now rate that joke.
You might be wondering
why did Jessica and I have
our backs turned.
That might seem
a little strange.
And that's because when
humans communicate,
they do so much more
than just use words.
There's eye gaze.
There's body language.
There's pauses, there's
intonation, all these things--
that guess what?
The computer is
not going to get.
So you really want to
focus on the words.
And when we're back to back,
it forces you to do that.
If I was talking to Jessica
and one of my prompts
was kind of confusing, she
might just kind of look at me,
and I'd probably just
naturally repeat myself.
But your computer is not
going to be able to do that.
So when you do back
to back, you're
forced to focus
on just the words.
Let's walk through an
example of a sample dialog
that we wrote down for a fake
action called cool animal
facts.
Will you be my user again?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
Of course, Cathy.
CATHY PEARL: All right.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: OK.
OK, Google.
Talk to Cool Animal Facts.
CATHY PEARL: Welcome
to Cool Animal Facts.
What animal would you
like to know about?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
I love penguins.
CATHY PEARL: Cool, penguins.
Would you like to know
about their habitat
or what they like to eat?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
What they like to eat.
CATHY PEARL: Penguins can eat
up to 13 pounds of fish, krill,
and squid a day.
By the way, male penguins
spend time sitting on the eggs
while the females
go out to get fish.
Now would you like to
hear more about penguins
or ask about another animal?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
I'm done, thanks.
CATHY PEARL: Sure.
Thanks for talking
to Cool Animal Facts.
Goodbye.
There's a couple of
things I want to point out
about this sample dialog.
The first one is how
we started things off.
We said welcome to
Cool Animal Facts.
That's pretty straightforward.
You know what we're
going to be about.
The next thing we did was we
had a very specific question--
which animal would you
like to know about?
We didn't say how you doing?
How can I help you?
That's going to be way too much
for the user to understand,
and they won't be successful.
The other thing I
want to point out
is, after I finished
telling Jessica
some facts about
penguins, I asked her,
do you want to hear
more about penguins
or ask about another animal?
And she didn't say
either of those things!
I told her what to say
and she didn't say it.
But that's OK.
Because she did something that
a person would very naturally do
to end the conversation
gracefully at that point, which
is, I'm done, thanks.
So you really need to remember
that people won't necessarily
say the exact thing
you've said, but they'll
say something
appropriate for that time
within the conversation.
I also want to mention we have
a lot of great best practices
and guidelines on our website
at actions.google.com/design.
This URL will be on the
last slide, as well.
And we've got great
stuff about how
to get started, how to
write sample dialogues, all
these things.
A lot of times, people ask us,
well, how many of these sample
dialogues do I need to write?
And there's no
hard and fast rule.
If your action is more
complex, you should probably
write some more.
But there's two types you
really want to focus on.
First, there's something
called the happy path.
That's when everything
is going great.
Your users are saying
things you can understand.
You're moving the
conversation along,
kind of like the Cool Animal
Facts one we just did.
But sometimes things
don't go perfectly.
Humans say things in a
really big variety of ways.
And there's going to
be times, especially
with voice and natural
language understanding, where
you didn't get what they said.
And you need to get them
gracefully back on track.
So be sure and write some
of those sample dialogues.
I'm going to be talking
a bit more about error
handling a little later.
And in the meantime, I'm going
to hand it off to Jessica
to talk about greetings
and setting expectations.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
So thanks, Cathy.
So Cathy and I, when we
first started this talk,
we introduced ourselves.
And we let you know
what we're going
to be talking about--
conversational actions
and how to make
them better, or make
them higher quality, at least.
And so setting expectation
is really important
when your action is first
being used by your users.
Because if we don't
have good expectations,
users could be confused on
what the possible opportunities
your action is providing.
And so saying expectations
and being very clear
on what options users have is
really important, especially
when it comes to the greeting.
So let's look at some greetings.
This is a fictional
action that we designed
called Pet Adoption.
In this action,
all it does is you
could browse different
animals that you
could adopt if you're looking
to adopt a furry friend.
And so let's look at the
example of a greeting
that someone had
used prior and we'll
be pulling this apart
and talking about how
we can make this better.
So the greeting that
they had was "Hello.
Let's find you your
perfect furry friend.
To start, say 'find an
animal' or ask a question."
There's a couple of
things that are not always
as obvious when it
comes to this greeting
and how it could get better.
So let's dive into it.
A user might read this or
hear this and think, oh,
I can ask any question.
And so a user might
say, are poodles smart?
But again, this action
doesn't actually
answer those type of questions.
It's all about adoption.
And it left this user
a little confused.
And most likely,
this action is going
to use the default
fallback intent,
just going, sorry,
what was that--
which isn't a great
experience for users.
So one of the big things, just
like Cathy mentioned earlier,
when you have in your greeting
a question that's very open,
it's hard for users
to necessarily know
what their options are.
And so saying things like
ask a question or how can
I help you could be a little
too vague in the greeting.
Those are great later
in the conversation,
once the user knows
more about your action
and what's possible.
Another thing which
is a little strange
is for the user having to say
find an animal when this action
is only about finding animals.
So it's an extra
trigger conversation
that the user has to do,
which is not necessary.
And so Kathy and I,
we played with this,
and we rewrote it
to being "Hello.
Let's find your perfect friend--
perfect pet.
What sort of animal
are you looking for?"
And so here it's a little
shorter and it's more explicit.
We're looking for a friend.
What kind of animal
would you like?
And then, of course,
in the back end,
we have to be able
to handle this.
And so this idea of an animal--
we need to handle and manage.
And so we're going to be
asking about an animal type.
It could be a dog, a cat,
or a different breed.
And so our action needs
to be able to process that
and that could be
really challenging
if we don't have
tools to help us.
And so many developers
use, when it
comes to actions like
Google, we use Dialogflow.
Dialogflow will be acting as
our natural language processor.
And it does what is
called intent matching.
It gets the user's utterance,
what the user says, and figures
out which one did
that match with best
to what the developer has put
into Dialogflow as options
or possible conversation paths.
And so it does that intent
matching, trying to figure
out-- the user said this.
Where does it go to?
And then, what's really great
is it does entity extraction.
Which means it could get
different pieces of data
from the user's utterance
and pass that as a parameter
to our back end.
And so the idea
of an animal type
could be grabbed
from the user's theme
and passed to us as
a parameter and we
could query our
database to pick out
the best animals for this user.
So to go back to this
particular example,
we have an intent where it's
a possible functionality
in Dialogflow called
availableAnimal.
And when a user says
the animal we're
going to be able to
grab that animal type,
pass it in as a
parameter, and it
goes to my back end-- to the
available animal function
that I have in my back end.
So that is a really short
kind of simple example
of a greeting.
Let's talk about one that's
a little meatier, that
has multiple options that we
want to present to the user.
So there is an
action called GDG,
which is Google Developer Group,
that Cathy and I both wrote,
which was fantastic.
She was amazing with it.
And this action was designed
as an open source project.
So then these GDGs, which are
community groups that focus
on Google technologies--
and they're amazing,
so shout out to GDGs--
where they could connect
their meet up API
to provide information like
the events that they have,
how many members they have,
who are the organizers.
And so for this one,
it's going to be
a little bit of a
more meatier greeting
that we're going to explore.
So Cathy and I
ended up with this.
"Welcome to GDG San Francisco!
I can tell you about the
organization, how many members
we have, or about events.
What would you like
to know about?"
And with this one, each
option is tied into Dialogflow
into a particular
intent that I have.
And so if a user says about
an organization or GDG,
it will hit my GDG
intent to Dialogflow.
And it'll process
information from there.
So the call of action is
really important in making sure
that for each shred of dialogue,
there's something connected
that the user could do next.
Another thing is,
this is written well.
But we want to play
with the sound of it.
How do you hear it?
How does this device
actually speak to the user?
Because this is the
first time the user
is going to use this action.
We want to make sure
that it's great.
So we use SSML, which is
a markup language, where
you could change the
audio of the Assistant.
You could change the pitch.
You can make it
talk slower, faster,
add really cool audio
elements into there, too.
It's fantastic.
And so we played with
SSML to make these changes
to the greeting.
So let's go to the console
and check that out.
OK.
So I'm here on my actions
on Google Console.
I am under test
in the simulator.
Right here in the middle is the
history of the conversation.
So you'll see the
back and forth.
On the right-hand side,
there's a lot of cool tabs.
We'll talk about
that in a moment.
So I'm going to invoke
this action, which
is a action that's
only accessible to me
at this moment, because
it's not deployed.
And it's all about
I/O. And they'll
have different options there.
So let me talk to my desktop.
DESKTOP FEMALE 1: Sure.
Getting the test
version of my test app.
[CHIME]
DESKTOP FEMALE 2:
Hello, Google I/O 2019.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
So now I'm going
to say GDG greeting,
which is going
to match my intent in
this particular project
and give that GDG San
Francisco greeting.
I would love for you
guys just to listen
to it to hear how it sounds.
DESKTOP FEMALE 2: Welcome
to GDG San Francisco.
I can tell you about the
organization, how many members
we have, or about events.
Which would you
like to know about?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
That sounds all right.
But let me show you where
you can make some changes
and play with SSML.
And so here on the
right-hand side,
we have the request
and response object.
And then we have an audio tab.
So let's click there.
And here you could see
the text they passed in
and that Dialogflow gives
to actions on Google,
Google Assistant
will say to the user.
And so I'm going to delete this.
And I'm going to
paste in some SSML
with that same verbiage
with a couple little tweaks.
So I'm going to
update this so we
can hear how this sounds now.
DESKTOP MALE: Welcome
to GDG San Francisco.
I can tell you about the
organization, how many members
we have, or about events?
Which would you
like to know about?
CATHY PEARL: So we made
a couple of small changes
here to make the introduction
sound a bit better.
The first one is that
we put a little bit
of a break between the
options that were presented
and the question.
And the reason for that
was that this is probably
the first time your
user has encountered
this particular action.
And they're not really
sure what to expect.
So there's a little
bit of time to do
some cognitive processing.
To think, oh, those
are the options,
which one am I going to use--
before we ask that question.
So we put in a short break.
The other one is that I actually
replaced the question mark
with a period at that
second end of question.
Which you might think
is a little odd.
Why would I do that?
That's because a lot of
times when we ask questions,
we don't always use a rising
intonation, like, how are you?
A lot of times when
we ask a question,
we're actually using a
falling intonation, the same
as when we make a statement.
Which one would
you like to know?
And that made it sound
a little more natural.
And of course, you're not going
to be able to probably listen
to every single prompt
within your action,
so you should focus
on a few key places,
such as the initial greeting.
Which again, is going to be the
first thing that the user is
going to hear and you want to
make a good first impression.
So spend some time
listening to that,
tweaking it, and seeing
what sounds the best.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Definitely.
Thanks, Cathy.
So of course, when
Cathy and I sat down,
we made these changes.
And we're, like, that's so cool.
But I don't want to have a
period and my user seeing that.
They're going to be,
like, Jessica, mm, mm.
That's not right grammar.
So first thing I did, of course,
was check our client library
to see how do we handle this.
So this is just a code snippet
using our JavaScript client
library.
And whenever you make
a simple response,
you could pass in two
different strings--
one for the speech
and one for the texts.
That way you could have a
little bit of a difference
when it comes to
when it's the audio
and when it's going to be what
the users are going to see.
And you could have the
experience slightly different
and unique for the different
types of modalities
that the user is going to
experience with your action.
So we talked about the greeting.
And now the next
thing you want to talk
about is, when
users come back, how
can you make it even better or
personalized for those users?
And so we're going to still talk
about the greeting, slightly.
But first, I just
want to tell you
a story about how I met Cathy.
Of course, this is exactly
our dialogue that we did.
I went hi.
I'm Jessica.
And I'm a developer advocate
for Google Assistant.
I talk about actions on Google.
Do you want to learn about
our codelabs, our sample
Actions, or our GitHub samples?
CATHY PEARL: Hm, codelabs.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: And
that's exactly how we met.
But you can imagine, the
10th time I meet Cathy,
if I go hi, I'm Jessica,
developer advocate, that's
not very nice to Cathy.
Because it just
shows I didn't even
remember that I
talked to her before.
That's not cool.
And so our actions might
have that same type
of feeling to our
users, as well.
And so let's talk about creating
custom greetings for users
that we've seen the first time
and users we see later in time.
So this is another
example that we have
where we have the
property called last seen.
And on the conversation
object, which
is the object that's being
passed between Google Assistant
Dialogflow and us as a
third party developer,
there is this
property, last seen.
And it gives you the
date, time, object
in a string format of the last
time you've seen the user.
So really simply,
you could do, if I've
seen them before I'm going
to give them the hi again.
Acknowledge that I've seen
them and potentially change
the greeting to be a little
shorter, and a little more
simpler.
And of course, if
we haven't seen them
before, we could give them
the longer greeting of hello,
this is who I am.
Let me tell you all the things.
And so you could use
something like that
to make your users
feel as though, yeah,
I acknowledge we've done
this before, which is great.
So let's go back to the
Pet Adoption example.
And again, this
one's all about being
able to find your next
furry friend for users.
And we're going to be
getting a lot of information
from the user.
So we could give the
best pet for that user.
And so I remember when I was
looking for a furry friend
about six years ago, I
wanted a poodle type of dog.
I definitely did not want
one that was a puppy.
But I was open to other ones.
And the size was OK.
I was open.
But the one thing that
was consistent in all
of my searches was my zip code.
And so let's talk about how
we could offer to the user
to remember the zip code so
that it's a little easier
for the user next time.
So I'll pretend that
we're in the conversation.
This is the first time
we asked for the zip code
and they give it to us, right?
And then our action
could provide--
here are the three
furry friends we found.
It has a really
great carousel, shows
the images of the animals.
And then, in that same
turn of conversation,
there's going to be another
bubble where it says,
do you want me or should
I remember that zip
code for next time?
That way the user doesn't
have to provide it again.
And then, of course, the
user could say yes or no.
And so let's see how we
could do this in code.
So this is, again,
in JavaScript.
And I have two intents that
are handling this information.
So let's focus on
the top intent.
Here we have the
available animals.
And let's pretend that
this gets activated
once they give me a zip code.
Then I do that, because
that'll be the last question
I ask the user.
And so what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to get that zip
code as a parameter.
And I'm going to save
it to the conversation
or conv.data, which is
short term data saving
that you could put in.
This is not a large
amount of data.
This is something that this
information will be saved only
for that part of
the conversation,
or those turns of
the conversation.
The moment the
user says goodbye.
That gets cleared out.
It's no longer stored.
And so it's really
great when you're
trying to gather different
pieces to generate a query.
You could save it to there.
Then once you've made the
query, then you clear that out.
And so we're going
to save it for here.
Because we're going to ask
the user if we want to save
their zip code for later.
So we're going to
save it to there.
Then, of course,
the action gives
the message of the animals
that they could find.
And then it gives
this message of,
should I remember the zip
code for the next time.
And we're using confirmations.
And confirmations
are the helper,
where we have multiple
[INAUDIBLE] helpers
that you could use
that we provide that do
different functionalities.
This one will handle the
yes/no type of questions.
And it does all the
variations of sure,
yeah, and tries to suss out
and get an actual yes or no
from the user.
So if the user kind of
gives something vague,
we'll reiterate and make sure
they get an explicit yes or no
for this yes or no question.
So that's the first
turn of conversation
after the user gives a zip code.
Then it goes to the user and
the user says, yes or no.
If the user says yes
or no, it's going
to hit our remember zip intent.
And it's going to
pass in confirmation
into that particular function.
And if it's true,
if they did say yes,
what we're going to do
is we're going to get now
from conv.data, which is
short term saving of data,
we're going to
grab that zip code
and now add it to
conv.user.storage.
That is long term
storage where it's
going to be saved over
multiple conversations.
And so if I talk to Cathy
once, and I save her zip code,
the next time I talk to
Cathy in three weeks,
I will still have her zip code.
So this is long term saving.
And then, of course, I'm
going to acknowledge the user,
saying, OK, I'll remember
that and continue
in the conversation.
And of course, we
don't to forget
that if the user says
no or they decline,
we will acknowledge
that, say no worries,
and then continue the
conversation, as well.
So just want to note that
whenever you're accessing user
storage, if you are in countries
that have regulations that
require developers to obtain
consent when obtaining user
information, you must use
the confirmation helper
when it comes to that.
So if you operate in
these countries that
have these restrictions,
please take note of that.
So helpers-- confirmation
is one of them.
And we provide other ways
that you can get information
from the user that's
really common.
For me, I don't necessarily want
to ask the user for their zip
code raw.
I want to be able to
ask it using place.
That way we can
get their location.
You can also get
other common things
like their name, their
photo, their email
by using permission, and then
other information like Google
Sign In where you can have them
log into your account, as well.
So helpers are ways
that we provide
and where you can get
information from the user
and Google Assistant
will temporarily
take control of the conversation
to handle that request, as
well.
So I definitely
highly recommend using
these to get data from the
user, especially when it
comes to names.
Because we all spell
names slightly different.
That way you can get the
actual name of the user.
CATHY PEARL: All right.
So earlier I talked a bit
about when things maybe
don't go quite right, when
somebody says something
that you didn't expect and
there's some sort of error.
Now humans have
misunderstandings all the time,
where we mishear each other
or misunderstand each other.
But we don't call
those hiccups errors.
I don't say, oh, I was
talking to Jessica last night.
And we had three errors.
Because we're so
good at repairing
the conversation gracefully.
And you can apply
that same principle
to help your users
get back on track when
they stumble in your action.
Hey, Jessica, what
did you do last night?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: I
went to [? Abuelita. ?]
CATHY PEARL: Sorry.
You went where?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
[? Abuelitas. ?]
CATHY PEARL: Oh,
great restaurant.
See?
Right there we had an error.
But we did a repair.
We quickly got back on track.
And again, if you follow
some of these best practices,
your actions can be
that smooth, as well.
Let's look at an example using
a sample dialogue of, again,
a fake action we designed
called Cathy's Chocolate Shop
where maybe we didn't handle
the error case very well.
Will you be my user again?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
Of course, Cathy.
CATHY PEARL: All right.
Let's go.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: OK, Google.
Talk to Cathy's Chocolate Shop.
CATHY PEARL: Welcome to
Cathy's Chocolate Shop.
I can give you
chocolate recipes,
tell you what chocolate
fact, or play a trivia game.
Which would you like?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Where--
where can I buy your chocolates?
CATHY PEARL: Sorry.
I can't understand the command.
Please say again.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
Store locations.
CATHY PEARL: Sorry.
I can't understand the command.
Please say again.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Ah.
Ah.
CATHY PEARL: Now you
might be thinking,
I would never write
a prompt like that.
But believe me, I got this from
a real life example out there.
So never say never.
What you really need to do here
is get people back on track
by providing them information
that's relevant right now.
Context sensitive
error handling is
key to building a
successful action.
So let's look at maybe
how we could have handled
this a little bit better.
Let's try this again.
Welcome to Cathy's
Chocolate Shop.
I can give you
chocolate recipes,
tell you a chocolate fact,
or play a trivia game.
Which would you like?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Where
can I buy your chocolates?
CATHY PEARL: I have chocolate
recipes, chocolate facts,
and a trivia game.
Which one would you like?
So here all we've done is
restate the options that
are available at that time.
And most of the time
something like this
is going to get people on track
and back on their merry way.
There's another type of
error prompt you can do,
which is similar, but
it's a little faster.
It's called a rapid reprompt.
And that works great if you've
only got maybe one or two types
of things you're asking for.
So let's hear how
that one sounds.
Welcome to Cathy's
Chocolate Shop.
Which would you like?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
How about a recipe?
CATHY PEARL: Sure, recipes.
Do you prefer dark
chocolate or milk chocolate?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
Oh, well, I like--
65% is good.
CATHY PEARL: Sorry.
Do you prefer dark
chocolate or milk chocolate?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Ah, dark.
CATHY PEARL: So
here, again, people
say things in a huge
variety of ways.
And if you're a
big chocolate fan,
you might want to talk about
the percentage of chocolate
that you like.
But maybe my action
doesn't understand that.
So I can quickly get
them back on track
with just dark or milk.
Another thing that you can do
to be really nice to your users
is to acknowledge when there
are things that you can't do.
We humans long to be understood.
It is very important to us.
Imagine I went to a hotel and
I'm talking to the concierge,
and I say, hey, can
you rent me a car?
And they say, I
don't understand.
Would you like me to
make dinner reservations?
I'd be like, no, can
you rent me a car?
It wouldn't make a lot of sense.
What they're really more
likely to say is, sorry.
I can't right you a car.
Are you interested in
dinner reservations?
So you should do something
like that for your actions.
Let's see what that sounds like.
Welcome to Cathy's
chocolate shop.
Which would you like?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Where
can I buy your chocolates?
CATHY PEARL: Sorry.
I'm not able to provide
store locations yet.
You can find locations on our
website, Cathy.chocolate.com.
Can I help with anything else?
So again, it was a very
explicit acknowledgment.
We didn't just say
I can't do that.
We said I can't do
store locations.
This also saves your user
a lot of frustration.
Because you've got
to remember, when
somebody comes into your action
and they ask for something
that you don't have,
they don't necessarily
know-- is it that your
action doesn't do that,
or did I just say it wrong?
Did they use the wrong keyword?
How about store locations?
How about where can I buy?
How about where are your stores?
They're going to be banging
their head against the wall,
thinking I don't
have the keyword.
I've got to keep trying.
When you stop and say,
hey, I can't do that thing,
then they know, oh, OK.
And they can move
on with their lives
and stop being so frustrated.
And the last thing I want
to say about error handling
is called escalated error.
Sometimes when you give them
that first error prompt,
it's not going to give them
all the information they really
need.
Most of the time it's going
to get them back on track.
But if they have another
error right away,
it probably means you didn't
give them enough information.
So you want to give
them a bit more detail.
So let's see how
that one sounds.
OK, dark.
Are you interested in
a recipe that's quick,
or do you have more time?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Well,
I mean, my partner's
birthday's tomorrow.
CATHY PEARL: Oh, sorry.
Was that a quick recipe
or something longer?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: I mean,
how long is it going to take?
CATHY PEARL: You can either
choose something quick, which
is under 30 minutes,
or longer, which could
be 30 minutes to overnight?
Which one would you like?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
30 minutes then.
CATHY PEARL: So
again, when Jessica
had an error the second
time, I obviously
wasn't helping her enough.
She needed to know,
well, what the heck does
quick mean before she
could make a decision.
So that's when you want
to get into a slightly
longer prompt with a bit
more information that
will get them back on track.
And check out the
Google I/O 2019 action
to hear some good examples
of context sensitive error
handling.
I want to say something a
little bit about persona.
When somebody hears a
voice or hears your action,
within the first second
they have already
made a mental model
of who is talking.
It's just something we do
as humans all the time.
So you really want
to get ahead of that
and define the persona or the
personality of your action
so they don't do it for you.
Now, this talk is not going
to get deep into persona.
I highly recommend
last year's talk
by Wally Brill,
"Creating A Persona,
What Does Your
Product Sound Like?"
He gets into great detail there.
But the one thing I
do want to mention
is if you're working
on your action,
building it in
Dialogflow, how do
you know you're still
following the guidelines
you set for your persona?
So I'm going to take an
example from Wally's talk,
that you're making
an airline action.
And imagine that you've
defined your persona
to be pretty casual,
pretty friendly.
And you've gotten
to the point where
you're writing a
prompt when you can't
find the user's reservation.
And you might write
something like this.
I'm sorry, but I am unable
to find your reservation.
So let's hear what that actually
sounds like in the console.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Yep.
So we're going to go
back to the console.
I've refreshed my action.
It's the same I/O action.
So let's start it.
DESKTOP FEMALE 1: Sure.
Here's the test
version of my test app.
[CHIME]
DESKTOP FEMALE 2:
Hello there again.
See?
I remembered that
we've talked before.
Don't you feel seen?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: OK.
So let me do reservation.
So I can get that.
DESKTOP FEMALE 2:
I am sorry, but I
am unable to find
your reservation.
CATHY PEARL: I know
it's a bit subtle,
but to me, that just
doesn't sound very good.
It's really formal and stiff.
It's long.
It doesn't use a contraction.
And it might be how we
would write something.
But when you say
it out loud, it's
not the way I would say it,
or a friendly customer service
agent.
So let's tweak it a bit.
Let's make it a
little bit shorter.
Let's put in a contraction,
and hear how this sounds.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: So
let's update and listen.
DESKTOP MALE: Sorry, but I
can't find your reservation.
CATHY PEARL: That sounds
a lot better to me.
Again, it's a kind
of a subtle change.
But to me, that's much more
how I would naturally say it.
As we mentioned
before, you're probably
not going to get the chance to
listen to every single prompt
in your action, and that's OK.
But you should focus on
some of the key areas,
such as your initial
prompt, and also, maybe,
places where there might be some
emotional reaction going on.
Here you've just told your
poor user that you cannot find
their airline reservation.
They're probably going
to be a bit upset.
So those are the
kinds of places where
you'll want to spend some extra
time thinking about, listening
to, and designing your prompts.
And to finish this
off, Jessica is
going to talk about how to
improve your action by looking
at the logs.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
Thanks, Cathy.
So we spent a lot of time
talking about conversation.
And I hope you do that and build
your conversation design really
well.
And then after you
do that, you're
going to build your action.
And then you're going to
put it for production.
And once you put
it in production,
your action is available on
over one billion devices.
And something that's really
cool about Google Assistant
is that our actions,
once they're
deployed on our
production level,
there's no downloading
needed for the user.
The user could just
simply say, hey, Google,
talk to, and then the action's
name, which is fantastic.
So most likely, you'll
get some users right away,
because people will be
finding your action.
So I'm going to talk about
one particular thing.
I want to highlight,
in Dialogflow,
there are three
different components
that I highly recommend
for developers
to use after your action's
deployed to look into so you
can make your action better.
First thing is training.
Next one is history,
and then analytics.
Each of these are fantastic.
But today we're going
to go over training
and talk more about that.
And so this is a page
view of a training.
And here you can actually see
the different conversations
you have with users.
And of course, these
logs do not obtain
or have any identifying
information about users.
They're just the raw
utterances that users
have with your action.
So let's click on one
and see what's in there.
So this is an interaction that
a user had with my action.
And let's walk through
this interaction.
So the first thing that
happens is the Google Assistant
triggers my welcome intent,
which my action does.
Welcome to GDG San Francisco.
Then after that,
the user said this.
How many peeps do you have?
Which my action did
not know what to do.
And so I hit my fallback intent.
And so it gave a kind of
a generic statement of,
like, sorry, what
was that, which isn't
a good experience for the user.
And most likely,
this term peeps is
slang in English, where it
usually refers to people.
And so I'm assuming
that this user meant
how many members do you have?
But they said it
slightly different.
And I need to take
into account for that.
And so what I could do
is I could Click next
to the intents, and
here it gives me
a list of all the
intents I currently have.
And there I could choose
to see which intent
does it best match with
that the user should
be able to get in return.
This one, in particular,
is my members' intent.
So I click on that.
And now, the next
time a user says
how many peeps do you have,
it's going to trigger my member
intent for that user.
When you do this, what
happens in the back end
is Dialogflow grabs
that user utterance-- so
how many peeps do you
have-- and adds that
to the intent training phrases.
So now it's included
in that model for you,
which is fantastic.
And of course,
there's going to be
times where you're going to
have interaction that you didn't
necessarily expect.
And so here you could
still click on that.
And there's an option on the
bottom called Create New.
And here you can
create a new intent.
Name it whenever
you want it to be.
So for the example of the
chocolate store locations,
you could create that
intent, grab that utterance,
and then go to the intense
portion in Dialogflow,
and then give a response there
and have that bit built out.
And so you can add
that functionality
while you're going through
your logs, which is great.
So we talked a lot
about many things.
So let's do a quick recap.
CATHY PEARL: So first we
learned how to get started,
sample dialogues.
Write them down.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Yeah.
And of course, you want
to say it out loud.
So you want to read all
your sample dialog out loud.
And then, of course,
you want to spend
some time saying expectations
and the greetings
for your users.
And then, of course,
you want to be
able to customize those
greetings for users
who come back for your action.
And then don't forget to
personalize the experience
by using helper methods.
CATHY PEARL: We also learned how
to get users back on track when
they say things your action
didn't expect and repair
the conversation gracefully.
Right, Jessica?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
Hi, I'm Jessica.
CATHY PEARL: Sorry.
Did you hear the part
about the air handling?
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: I did.
Yeah.
CATHY PEARL: All right.
Another thing you can
do is to double check
that you're building
according to the spec you set
for your persona.
And you can do that by
listening to your prompts
out loud throughout
the building process.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA:
And of course,
quantifying them
using SSML, so you
could create really rich
experience for your users.
And then finally, once your
actions are out for production,
go through the logs so you can
make your action even better.
CATHY PEARL: If you want to
get started building actions,
we've got a lot of
great resources for you.
There's Actions on Google
Docs, conversation design best
practices, and of
course, codelabs
to see examples of things
people have already built.
Thank you so much.
JESSICA EARLY-CHA: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]